garding motivation und heute werde ich
auf deutsch sprechen
ich mache hier sehr viele video zum
thema sprachen lernen warum weil ich
habe sehr gern sprachen zu lernen und
ich glaube dass alle vier leute alle
menschen können das machen sie haben die
fähigkeit sprachen zu lernen und das
wichtigste ist motivation und darüber
sind drei wichtige fragen
zuerst kann ich das tun
das heißt kann ich eine fremdsprache
lernen kann ich eine person geläufigkeit
oder oder flüssig flüssigkeit erreichen
in einer fremdsprache man muss das
glauben
ich weiß dass wenn man das nie gemacht
habe dann ist es schwer
also genug vertrauen zu haben also zu
glauben dass man kann diese ziel
erreichen also bevor ich französisch
gelernt hatte zu einer ziemlich hoch
niveau das habe ich ich habe also bevor
ich diese erfahrung hätte dann also
hatte dann doch dann hatte ich nicht
diese vertrauen
und deswegen fielen und nach ich ich
also französisch habe dann habe ich ihn
eh sich japanisch spanisch und viele
andere sprache gelernt aber dieser
vertrauen was ihr wichtig und wenn sie
oder du das nie gemacht habe hat hast
dann musst du das also glauben weil ich
ich bin überzeugt wir haben alle diese
fähigkeit
du musst sagen ja das kann ich tun wenn
diese wenn du glaubst du dass du das
nicht tun kann
dann ist es besser nicht zu fortsetzen
wenn du zum beispiel gäste auf eine
reise und du glaubst du kommt nicht zum
endpunkt dann ist es besser nicht auf
diese reise zu fahren
zuerst der frage kann ich das tun
die antwort ist ja das kann es das geben
werde ich du zur zweite frage
funktioniert das das heißt die methode
verwendet ist es effektiv oder ist ist
es also gleich die effektivste methode
gibt
ich glaube also mein main methode das
heißt sehr viel höheren der sehr viel
lesen und die schwerpunkt auf
verständnis auch vokabeln also wartet
zuzusetzen
für mich ist das meist effektiv
effektivste methode und aber wenn du
glaubst ein oder andere leute haben
andere haltungen herrn andere also ideen
also hauptsächlich macht man muss
dranbleiben man muss vorzeichen und man
muss glauben wenn du glaubst dann dede
effektiv effektiv hayek oder weiß nicht
deine methode dann der iss funktioniert
also zweite frage funktioniert das du
machst muss glauben ja das funktioniert
und dritte frage ist es wert weil es ist
es nicht so einfach kann sprache zu
lernen
das kann sehr viel spaß machen das kann
interessant sein aber es ist auch ein
bisschen schwierig weil wenn man fängt
an
dann muss man sehr viele uninteressante
inhalten lesen und hören viele also neue
wörter lernen und vergessen nun noch
einmal lernen noch einmal vergessen und
de
auch wenn man beginnt mit mehr
interessanten also authentisch
sie erinnerten zu zuletzt übte also
lernen und studieren
auch das gibt es immer so viele neue
also welcher zur neuerburg kabel und das
ist sehr viel arbeiten wenn man fängt
dann zu sprechen dann mag dann sehr
viele fehler und jetzt ich ich mache
immer sehr gut wäre wenn ich deutsch
spreche aber aber es ist wert weil es
gibt so viel also leute zu kennen von
andere kulturen also in verschiedene
länder also reisen und mit diese leute
umzugehen und und lesen also durch alle
ist nicht lese oder cs kann man
broadcast einladen also ich habe zum
beispiel ich wollte heute ein bisschen
also deutsche üben und dann habe ich
eine gebäudes gefunden an von thomas
mann wollte von joseph von österreich
er spricht über effektiv management das
präsent ist als sehr interessante
podcast podcast über geschichte so kann
man sehr viele dinge lernen nicht nur
der dd die sprache so für mich ist es
wäre aber jedem muss das für sich selbst
entscheiden
wenn du glaubst wenn du findest dass es
nicht wert ist dann ich glaube du wirst
nicht erfolg haben deswegen noch einmal
drei fragen kann ich das tun
funktioniert es ist es wert wenn diese
drei tage du ja sagen kann dann wirst du
genug motivation haben deine ziel zu
erreichen
und also flüssig auf eine andere sprache
sprechen können
danke wiedersehen tschüs